have you thought about going vegan
um
I I eat some vegan meals I'm just not
gonna go all the way vegan I feel like
it's like a cleanest thing like I just
eat you know what I'm saying when I was
like maybe like a week yeah when I've
been bullshitting with the tequila too
hard you feel me I think Tequila's vegan
it's Agave for sure for sure damn
they're vegan but uh I'll lick a vegan
bro
I would hope so yeah like [ __ ] I'll look
a vegan bro I'm like is there something
about because you said it like you know
if I could drink a tequila too much it's
honey Hennessy is just grapes you know
what I'm saying so it's like all this
[ __ ] is fruit you're a Tequila man
nowadays yeah I used to be a cognac it's
a different drunk isn't it
I just um I feel like cognac for when
you alone because the white cognac made
me tired and ready to be gone out that's
I feel that's why people fight when they
are Hennessy and [ __ ] because they be
down the tire it's a violent drunk yeah
is a little more fun happy drunk happy
drunk oh God
yeah I think something about the
pandemic put tequila on in a new way
with like you know the casa and the
class Amigos and yeah casamigos took off
on that yeah shout out to George Clooney
George Clooney that's his that's his uh
we was drinking 42 in the panty though
clone yeah I don't know where that came
from with that cost Amigo [ __ ] but we
was drinking 42 heavy right before that
[ __ ] everybody a little price yeah 42 is
a little overrated that kind of with
that price it's a little overrated it's
about the bottle
damn yeah crazy must have been a rough
night huh well I wasn't at all I was
drinking water in between bro that's
smart yeah I drank Jason much water you
know you're professional when you take
your shot and then you take a big big
gulp of water and then you just do that
the whole night you should be all right
I've done I got OCD bro I can't be
remotely thirsty so I just drink water a
lot yeah you are you OCD with all
aspects of life or just hell no just
water like it was like if I'm thirsty
when I'm thirsty I I can't even go to
bed without seeing a bottle of water
first like I gotta see that movie I'm
gonna not go to sleep but I bet I can't
eat unless like I I've like run out of a
drink at a restaurant I've stopped
eating until they remember refill
I have to have a drink with my food at
all times why you'd be scared you're
gonna need the Heimlich or something nah
just it's just I don't know bro it's
just I just like to eat with with drinks
I feel it I mean I feel it